the winner of the $1,000,000 and the
star of the headline show in Las Vegas
is
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] you won man yeah that's crazy
hey honestly how are you feeling right
now I'm really happy I can't stop
smiling
I don't think I've ever smelled this
much please your face hurt yet yeah yeah
I mean it's a far cry for what you look
like on the stage can I just say you
look visibly anxious almost in agony I
mean what were you thinking before they
called your name well it was just kind
of the lead-up to it you know wait when
Courtney go out and then Michael cutter
got out that that's what really lost it
for me I just kind of went crazy degree
surprised yeah very like it was a
rollercoaster for me and just you know
I've been hanging out with all these
guys a long time when each person went
home I'm just like wow we're breaking it
is and so it's just such a mix of
emotions that I couldn't really hold it
in so I just all like the only thing I
could do was start pacing like I had to
pace I couldn't head was between your
legs I mean they were telling me like
staying in the squad I was like no I
can't do that right now
at what point were you up there thinking
I might actually have a shot of winning
this entire thing it was only when it
was up to me and zucrow yeah that was it
I mean like because Brian King Joseph I
mean he's an incredible show I mean
everyone is incredible and but when it
was up to me and succour I was like wait
a second oh my god they win this thing
and then yeah and then when Tyra
announced you as the winner
your first thought it could mean
expletive I mean I just I did I I was
speechless yeah you know I was like I
just a close-up magician just won
America's Got Talent that's
unprecedented I especially not just
close up with just specifically cards
cards right you know and I'm like wow
this card magic people like hard magic
like I didn't even think I was gonna
make it past the auditions with that
really well yeah it's closed up and
there's a stage full of 3,000 people you
know it's just just crazy that's how
good you are and I feel like you stepped
it up for the finals yeah right yeah and
I have to thank Simon for that Bush he
pushed me to do it if it wasn't for him
I wouldn't have done that I would have
actually done what I did for the for
today's show yeah
on Tuesday okay that's what I would have
done
Wow yeah aren't you glad you with how
would you sum up this entire experience
in one word I am super honored I have
learned so much and it was such a
learning experience I've grown so much
as a as a performer and as a person and
I want to thank everyone involved I also
want to especially thank Kayla my
producer you have stuck with me from the
beginning and you you believed in me and
you were the reason why I did AGT is
because of you you convinced me that I
was good enough to actually do it and I
hope you're hearing this Kayla really
I'm talking your Marlo - you can say
that again we're going live tomorrow
together all right real quick how are
you gonna celebrate tonight just with my
friends just friends and we're just
gonna miss with you tonight Casey Casey
career real quick fiance hello I mean
how stoked are you I mean what was it
what was your reaction when you were
they announce him as the winner were you
what point were you like oh my god I
think he's gonna win a trip seeing him
on this on this stage and on TV and you
know showing his talent it's crazy so
I'm like oh my god that's actually my
fiance yeah Wow like you're the lucky
girl
I gotta say Tyra all season long has
been say how sexy is were you like Tyra
don't come from my man
everyone liked Heidi kiss me she was
totally okay with it I didn't take it
off and she sighs she's like yeah it's
Heidi this time I got the other day's
going home with you right well you guys
congratulations dude I mean enjoy
tonight because you you have a busy life
ahead our wedding planning at all it
will be next year
[Music]